As always, Super Bowl LVII was a huge deal
for commercial lovers, but there were a
few big ads during the Big Game that were
more than a little confusing. Here's why.
The Super Bowl is known for wild TV team-ups
and pop culture collabs, like Ozzy Osbourne and
Justin Bieber, or Dr. Evil and General Motors. In
2023, there's "The Busch Guy" and Sarah McLachlan,
John Cena's team-up with Experian, and Budweiser
betting big on a Kevin Bacon-voiced spot.
But instead of just bringing together
celebrities and brands like the NFL
championship game always does, Super Bowl
LVII kicked off a new trend that will see
the companies themselves linking up
for the widely-watched sports event.
"It's Miller Time."
A February 9, 2023 report from The
Hollywood Reporter described how
brands are pooling their resources and
star power this year, with marketers
being on the prowl more than ever now for
brand collabs as a way to mitigate costs.
Warner Bros. Discovery CEO David Zaslav
called the advertising market "very weak"
back in November 2022, and it's reportedly even
worse these days than it was during the peak of
the COVID-19 pandemic. As a result, TV viewers saw
companies partnering up for commercials this year
— potentially muddying the waters when it comes to
what viewers will actually take away from the ad.
"Brad was so much better for you.
You should have gone with Brad.
"Yeah, Brad."
"Are you serious?"
For example: Michelob ULTRA's Super Bowl
collaboration with Netflix for its new golf
documentary series "Full Swing." The first episode
actually "premieres" via a QR code on the can,
as Ricardo Marques, vice president of marketing
for Michelob ULTRA, explained in a statement:
"If you scan our Michelob Ultra
can, you can access Episode One
of the show exclusively for a period
of 24 hours [...] Thematically this is
beautifully aligned with our entire
campaign, and also gives something
of added value to our audience, which is
exclusive access to this amazing show."
In addition to Michelob, Netflix also
teamed up with GM this year for a Will
Ferrell-led commercial that sees him portraying
popular characters like Dustin Henderson from
"Stranger Things" and a competitor on "Squid
Game" — in an ad about … electric vehicles?
In similar fashion, brands
like Coors and DraftKings,
Marvel and Heineken, Michelob and
Instacart, and a number of others,
also decided to work together on Super Bowl
ads this year, which, according to marketing
execs who spoke to The Hollywood Reporter
under the condition of anonymity, is all due
to the market climate. Northwestern University
marketing professor Tim Calkins told the outlet,
"The efficiency argument is pretty compelling,
because doing a Super Bowl ad campaign is
enormously expensive. It's not just the ad
time, it's everything that goes around it,
all the other events, all the other
activities, that becomes wildly expensive."
Netflix didn't do any stand-alone ads this
year during the big game, which is a first for
the streaming giant. According to The Hollywood
Reporter, GM gave Netflix full and total control
over creating their commercial and simply provided
the vehicles for the entertainment company to
use however they saw fit. Deborah Wahl, chief
marketing officer at GM, said in a statement,
"Netflix is a great partner because of the
company's compelling storytelling, commitment
to sustainability and track record of sparking
conversations that shape cultural trends."
Marketing executives who spoke to The
Hollywood Reporter insist that the
collabs are multi-million-dollar efforts
by the companies to save themselves from
spending too much on an ad that could
possibly miss the mark. Media consultant
Brad Adgate says it was a milestone Big
Game, advertising-wise, telling the outlet,
"Years from now, we'll look back on this and
say this was kind of a watershed moment."